make it sound like a bird would be
playing it
oh like a like a bird would be playing a
bird themed song please
only do chords a bird can play okay
did not disappoint
[Music]
these are songs that a bird could say
if it could sing a song like this
he would tell you that you can't hold an
american bald eagle
any time you want
[Music]
hello hello guys how are you oh i'm
doing all right
just dandy yeah we're coming back with a
lot of bird knowledge for you
jake so that's crappy yeah so strap in
everybody because i'm about to find out
just as much as
as you all are about to find out because
apparently ren
and matt went on an excursion on friday
to into bird law you could say yeah well
i less into bird law and more about just
like
birds oh you there were a lot of
problems though along the way that
related to bird law i mean i guess like
production issues to be able to like
make this thing happen
right yes yeah okay so you guys went up
as we talked about on the last episode
were you on that episode
we talked about the first time we talked
about no no oh okay
yeah we gave it we basically gave an
update uh about why uh
we're we didn't realize we could not
put a camera on a peregrine falcon
because it's literally against the law
because peregrine falcons are native to
america here
and it's against the law to commercially
use a native
native wildlife i don't think it's
limited to just birds
i thought it was but apparently this is
like an actual like wildlife law
so if if it's native you can't
commercially use it
if it's imported if you bring it from
another place or
you're killing the traffic if you ship
the bird overseas
and then shoot with this is like bird
slavery dude this is messed up why is
that legal
you go through you go three miles off
the coast of california
and then you can film with the board it
seems like
it would be better that they're in their
natural habitats right when you're
filming with them but
like game of thrones for instance i
think they used like some some american
wolves but
it was okay because they shot with them
in ireland yeah
here's another here's a bird law bird
fact for you um
they when they shot like the the windex
commercials with the with the ravens
um they had to they used this like um
animal safe dye to dye the ravens all
the way black because
the ravens that are non-native to our
country have like a white
i think yeah they've got a white neck
white neck yeah so if you want a
completely black raven and you want to
shoot it in america
here in the old united states you gotta
die of that bird
you better die that bird die that bird
yeah okay so
yeah considering you're going through
all the footage right now you're
probably way more familiar with this
than i am now
i've got like a weaker fuzziness yeah
yeah we got a lot of things to talk
about today i want to talk about that i
also want to talk about what
what is happening right now are you
talking about the fact that we raised
ninety thousand dollars in five minutes
yes for charity yeah today yeah dude the
the nft drop evan so we'll get to that
we'll get to that but first just take us
into the journey of your guys's
excursion to go film with these birds
yes so we won we uh drove up to pesa
robles
which is three hours north of here three
four hours north of here uh wine country
california
and we stayed just outside of town
thursday night and got up early
friday morning so here's the problem
we're heading up there or rather we're
planning on heading up there
and the weather forecast was awful it
was like 60 chance of rain
cold all day very low chance that we
would actually get to fly with these
birds and
or have these birds fly around because
they're they they don't fly in the rain
they're able to get wet
it's actually when they they get cleaned
off but they're not going to let them
out and go flying in the rain
so if it's raining we can't film that's
a big problem so we're thinking of
staying an extra day and shooting
saturday morning so we're really
concerned about this is like our number
one concern
and uh friday morning we get out there
and it's like really nice
yeah super nice i mean there are clouds
all over the place but like
not like the the hazy clouds that you
get when it's like socked in you know
so it was actually really sunny for a
lot of the day
and so it ended up being really nice we
shot with a whole bunch of birds i gotta
carry a whole bunch of birds
by i gotta hold them what kind of birds
what kind of birds well they had a
couple sacred falcons
uh that were pretty sweet those were the
main ones we were working with they're
uh
from north africa and uh so that's why
we're able to
commercialize them by putting a camera
on their back yeah yeah but they also
had a they had a bald eagle too
yeah yeah so they had a lot of birds
they had a bald eagle which
was missing half a wing because it got
shot by uh someone
i don't know who shoots bald eagles but
apparently you just hop around now
shoot yeah he hops around he's he never
leaves his cage really like they take
him out for like stuff but like
he doesn't um he doesn't fly he doesn't
soar amongst the clouds
i heard that if you shoot i heard that
if you shoot a bald eagle
uh that um george washington will hop
out
for out of nowhere with you he'll hop
out of your wallet if you have a one
dollar bill and it'll just
materialize yeah so something that i
didn't
know so like through the we're you know
we're filming these little info bits
because
uh right off the bat we shot right away
with the two falcons putting the camera
on the back and that was like its own
little thing
and when you fly them you have to like
give them treats so like they actually
fly up to you and they eat their their
you know their little treat and they fly
around more they come back for their
treat but they get full pretty quickly
and then they don't fly anymore and so
you have to actually let them sit and
digest and there's this whole process
where it's like
it actually sits in their stomach and
you can touch their stomach because it's
exposed
they don't have a rib cage i didn't know
birds do not have rib cages yeah
and by the way y'all if you'd like to
know what it's called that little
section of their chest
it's called a crop okay and the crop is
where they store their food
all right while it's being digested and
the thing is
if you put more food into that crop then
it it like it almost like it piles up
essentially
so so the stuff that's like half
digested uh
it can't like you know filter through
the crop i love this so much because
it's like
this is all stuff i learned as well yeah
but you know that was a week ago and i'm
kind of fuzzy on the details but you've
sat all day today just
watching those details over and over
editing this video so you're like very
familiar with it yeah and it's like
you're saying i'm like oh that's right
that's right that's right yeah yeah and
uh so what's fascinating is because you
can't
their stomach is like so visible they
can actually see when they're ready to
fly again because they're like oh your
food's digested
wow there's a lump yeah there's like an
actual physical lump they even
they guided my finger to poke their
stomach and i was like whoa that's a
lump all right
yeah yeah they evolve out of having
ribcages
when from when they were dinosaurs i
don't know about his work i don't know
about the evolution
aspect here but yeah yeah so but i don't
but i do know it's called crop rot
when crop right when it rots in there
like it does
and that can actually kill the bird like
it's very dangerous
that we had to be very strict with when
we could fly with them so once we flew
for like five minutes that bird was done
for a couple hours yeah
so right off the bat that was the first
thing we did just to maximize our time
of the day flew with these two birds
and then we went and hung out with some
hawks uh they weren't a red-tailed hawk
it was another type of hawk
because red tails are native to america
yeah um i can't remember the name yeah
anyway it was a cool hawk and you know
what's the cool thing here's another
bird fact for you pretty much pretty
much all the birds of prey that they had
at the this falconry experience um
they're all really smart animals right
so you need to you need to constantly
entertain them
um they're they and one thing they do is
play fetch
yeah right you isn't it crazy to have
seen those like hawks and the falcons
like
literally they go over they pick up a
toy they bring it back and drop it and
like sometimes they'll even like hop
around for the toys yeah with the toy
they'll like grab they'll have a toy in
their hand and they'll hop around and
they look like little dogs you know
giving the the ball back to their
another thing so
the falconry experience falcon like
falconers
i always just thought there were a
specific subset of bird trainers that
only deal with falcons apparently no
falconry applies to all birds of prey
like
uh you know eagles owls hawks like the
kleenex of bird training
right because it's yeah it's that kind
of bird trainer yeah the the jello
trainers the
band-aids i could be totally wrong about
this but i thought that
all like falcon is like in the genus of
the you know ordering of the species
like raptors
or something yeah raptors that yeah so
all oh yeah
they're all in the same same yeah i
thought they were all the same
family or i bet they are but is that
family like a falcon name
i thought so but okay maybe i'm wrong
maybe i don't know that's that's
something we didn't learn that that is
not a bird fact we learned
no that's cyber that may not be a fact
at all i just
i think i remember we would drop it from
being younger and then
you know going to like nature centers as
a kid and like they have the birds and
then they they tell you about the birds
and it's it's one of those you know yeah
i i do know that the red tail hawk
is technically a buzzard not a hug yes
yeah
yes what birdbath it's a buzzard
[Laughter]
the word buzzard or the name was uh made
famous by disney because
uh as an association with like like
vultures right like all the buzzers are
out they're gonna get you
but it's like technically a buzzard is
just a type of hawk huh
yeah which was which are not
wizards yeah yeah exactly it's like
there's hawks and buzzards they look
very
so not all buzzards are hawks but all
hawks are buzzards
no um i think is it i think it's the
other way around
oh my gosh our bird facts are confusing
there's yeah there are a lot of bird
effects flying around so like
if you're here to find out the truth
about
the raptor family of birds like good
luck because you're not gonna find it
here
yeah um and so like uh as part of this i
i got to hold a lot of these birds like
i got to hold the hawks the falcons on
my arm
which was a really cool experience like
like growing up like the peregrine
falcon was like my
favorite animal uh and yeah and so like
being and like i just i love birds of
prey so like having
like being being this close to them
petting them they have these softest
feathers
yeah especially especially the owls yeah
i've always wanted so i held an owl i
forget what type of vowel it was but
his name is jack it was not a barn it
was it was um it was a different type
because they got the eyebrows that go
really up like they're failing or
something like that
and a wise owl really so his name is
jack short for jack-o'-lantern because
he kind of looks like a jack-o'-lantern
and so this is what blew me away
apparently owls are
idiots yeah because because their eyes
are so big they don't have a whole lot
of room
in their head for their brains so
they're kind of dumb but
like no like she's like she streams like
oh yeah this hawk here he's such a dumb
dumb he's so stupid
i was like whoa he's right here like he
can hear you he's like exactly and he
doesn't understand
anything um yeah so apparently uh owls
are not particularly smart
amongst other birds whereas like falcons
and eagles are yeah
fairly smart and that's there's another
bird fact for it that's how they
get hit so much they get hit by cars a
lot because
they they use almost 100 of their brain
to focus on the prey
right so they have this like laser
vision on their prey so if they
if they're even though they have this
amazing peripheral eyesight when they
need it
when they're focused on their prey
they're like swooping down on it and
they have they specifically focus
on that animal they don't have the
process yeah so they can't see they
can't see around them
so if there's a car with you know even
if they have brights on it's not gonna
matter they're not gonna be able to see
that
also that owl had the largest eyes they
were huge they had to have been over an
inch in diameter like a giant like
huge that's how they get that marbles
and they
they can't move their eyes and that was
something i knew from like from
childhood like i
uh that's why owls are able to move
their heads like completely around is
because
their eyes don't move uh they're
actually fused to the back of their
skull or something like that and so they
have to move their
their head around anytime they look uh
but yeah so
the owl was pretty sweet uh definitely
by far the softest
feathers of any bird i've ever touched
because later on they had some macaws
some parrots
and like you feel their feathers and
like this is what i expect a bird to
feel like
but the owl felt like like those really
really soft like microfiber blankets
that you can get you know like the
really fancy
super hyper soft blankets that's what
this owl felt like
yeah those are made out of owl i heard
yeah that is the old building they're
not made out of feathers this straight
up just made out of owl
yeah they just take an owl that's right
there yeah that's why i get eyeballs
sometimes in mine
that explains yeah yeah yeah that
explains the golf ball sized
eyeball yeah i was wondering what that
was i i i do a lot of things here at
corridor that i never would have
expected to be able to like
say that i've done in my life for
instance i never expected to be able to
say
i did the motion capture for draco
malfoy dunking harry potter
like literally that is something i never
expected to say that i i've done
the other thing i never expected to say
is that i have been
slapped in the face pretty hard by a
bald eagle what did you say to it
yeah i said america he sucks and he's
like
damn democratic socialism
no so like you're gonna take my gun slap
so i will point out that it was the bird
who touched me
i didn't touch the eagle and that is
important because it is
sure sure buddy so all these other uh
uh birds i was able to hold and touch
and whatnot but the eagle
was different so a bald eagle apparently
it's against the law
to interact with you cannot touch a bald
eagle without a special license which
these falconers obviously have
and so because of that i wasn't allowed
to hold the eagle um
and and yeah and so the al all these
birds do this weird thing where
they're sitting down normally and then
they like they start falling off or they
they
try to fly away so they flap their wings
a lot and they sometimes kind of like
fall upside down like they're hanging
from
from the the falconer's arm okay i've
seen the renaissance fair kind of like
yeah kind of hang down they got like
these straps that are uh
you know wrapped around their feet so
they can't fly away and the the falconer
actually has to hold down
pretty hard because one of those hawks
uh not the buzzard
the big the big hawk that i was holding
tried to fly away at one point and it
was
hard to keep that thing down i was like
holding on with all my life i was like i
will not be responsible
get out of here i'm coming with you yeah
cause like they have a lot of force just
like thrown out because they are
incredibly light
if you've got one on each arm do you
think it could lift you no no like up
yeah
philadelphia episode where charlie does
the up thing but he does it with a bunch
of like
pigeons oh my god yeah like
i was blown away by how light they were
like i could like after a while i
started getting tired with the massive
buzzard on my arm but like
it it wasn't that heavy at all like
and so like being able to have that much
surface area on their wings
and the muscle to throw it down like
that it was a surprising amount of force
lifting up off my arm like i felt my arm
lifting every time anyway so they'd fall
off and like try to like
get back on and then get their balance
back and yeah and so that's what
happened to the eagle the eagle like
tried to like fly away or you know do
whatever
and his arm went out like this like and
hit me right in the face i don't know if
he got on camera or not oh definitely
it's in the video
no the moment that you showed me wasn't
it the one where you then turned a
camera
like i can't believe like i just got
slapped by a bald eagle it's definitely
in there
never mind yeah and by the way guys for
a little bit of context i had to edit
this whole video in three days
to send to like insta 360.
so i it's kind of like two two yeah
yeah yeah we were shooting a bunch of
stuff on like from the hours and hours
of footage we had down to
and thank you shout out to dean who
helped me today um get this done
uh but yeah we did it so hell yeah
brother hell yeah
good man i'm really glad that was a lot
to get through and
yeah yeah yeah it's been a crunchy few
weeks
and it has been it's been it's been uh
very busy
hey guys brandi o'daniel here back with
another exciting
podcast sponsorship today's sponsor is
of course the wonderful the epic the
amazing
the incredible story blocks if you don't
know
storyblocks is the complete stock
solution for all of your stock asset
needs you're always going to get to that
point in the post-production process
where you need a little something to
just tune up your video that can be
everything from b-roll and video
to after effects templates and motion
graphics to
audio and music storyblocks has
a virtually unlimited library with over
one million
royalty-free high-quality assets which
allow you
to take those and put them in your
videos and make your videos better
without having to go off and shoot and
create and fabricate and produce other
assets
on your own this saves you a lot of time
and money and with storybox's
unlimited all-access plan you can get
unlimited downloads
royalty free for any type of project
that you want
meaning you can use them in commercials
you can use them in your own youtube
videos you can monetize them you cannot
monetize them you can send them to your
friend you can send them to grandma
send them to your crush do kids still
use the word crush anyways
if you guys are interested in getting
started and trying it out for yourself
head on over to storybox.com
corridor cast that's storyblocks.com
or cast now where do we go from here we
go back to the podcast
it's been people weeks two weeks
yeah so yeah so yeah uh shot with these
birds is a really cool time
okay so they they got the camera they
got a camera
fake ahead of time to practice flying
with so that they can get used to it but
even
with that they uh what i was really
hoping for
in through this whole project was to be
able to get the falcon go up a couple
thousand feet and then just dive
straight down i thought that'd be a
really incredible footage
but what ended up happening is that they
would fly around they actually flew
quite a bit but they never really got
more than a few feet off the ground
until later in the day we went to this
hill and she flew down the hill and flew
around it was really cool
it looks a lot like drone footage like
racing drone footage
because usually like when i'm flying
like that i like to fly just a few feet
off the ground like
proximity style and it was like wow
eagles sorry
falcons nature's drones how'd the uh
stabilization turn out
on the back of the bird pretty good so
unfortunately the birds are flapping
pretty hard and
the insta360 go 2 i don't have the
camera is
can stabilize everything in the yaw one
axis like it can twist
and over end like this very well it
stabilizes
that perfectly any up and down or left
and right
not as much uh so when it the bird
flapping it's going up and down quite a
bit so there's a little bit of like
up and down shutter or flittering
fluttering yeah
but you can crop in a little bit so
there's a few different modes you can
set your warping to you can make it
ultra wide and that's where it has the
least amount of stabilization it didn't
look that good but when you set it to
linear it it actually does like the dis
dorsion
sorry the warping of a crop uh and that
gives it more room to
to stabilize and that actually looked
really good yeah and if you said it uh i
ended up not rendering any of these but
if you said it's narrow it actually
crops in on that and gives you even more
room to stabilize okay but what i ended
up finding
from that i watched a sorry i watched a
few things from that
with with it on narrow uh crop with more
stabilization but the problem is that
like the
the camera is flapping so much it's
inserting rolling shutter into the image
itself
which is just a a a side effect of using
a cmos sensor it's
every single camera that we use has that
so if you whip your camera around
all the all the walls or straight lines
are going to curve a little bit yeah and
so when you're
stabilizing that you're it's not going
to be like proper so that's what you're
kind of seeing
like that little bit of fluttering
you're seeing is a little bit of that
actual rolling shutter
yeah coming through being stabilized
yeah but it's a weird thing but like you
know
at the same time it it's not for the
entire flight
it's only for the the hard flapping
moments because the thing is like
another thing that we ran into that was
a pretty big problem was the lack of
wind at the front of the deck that's
right
and right and because there's no wind uh
for the birds to
have enough lift to be able to use the
wind to
um they have to use their their energy
and expend all their energy on flapping
their wings um so they get tired and
they don't yeah until they get tired and
so the footage doesn't look as good but
like
once the the wind started to pick up
they can soar a lot more and they can
glide
and so those gliding shots where they're
like banking yeah and they're like
going through trees and stuff some of
the shots look pretty sweet
one shot that literally i was like that
that was it that was amazing because i
was reviewing it and
uh the falcon i think it was uh kaito
the the female
was banking around and so she was
turning like this
soaring and her head was turned towards
camera and it's like it literally felt
like i was on the back of a dragon just
like
as swedish falcon was just like looking
at where it's flying it was cool
yeah yeah imagine that can you imagine
riding a giant bird like that like
you know oh i can imagine it because i
saw it
and you guys can see it too this weekend
all of you guys will see it very soon
oh actually so one of the coolest
stories that one of these falconers told
us was that she was in belize and she
was able to fly with these falcons
paragliding no not police nepal oh nepal
yeah like up in
freaking himalayas wow yeah yeah so she
was able to jump off of a cliff
and have like falcons flying with her
motorcycle like paragliding yeah or
maybe it was just regular paragraphs
she was she you know one of those like
parachutes that you fly yeah
have you seen me uh meet the parents
obviously
yes everyone's seen that movie and when
they meet when he goes to meet owen
wilson
and he's in like this huge house and
he's like the perfect boyfriend
oh wasn't he the guy who like like the
story that's that's one time i was a
paranoid
thing out of a giant single piece of
wood yeah yeah it is one of those
reminds me of it's like so i was i was
paragliding it was in nepal
you know i had my falcons next to me and
i just
and i just thought oh my god i should
make this investment
yeah so funny dude that movie is classic
yeah it is it really is it's one of the
one of the greats
oh one other thing so what's so wild is
that they've got all these birds all
over the place and so we went into their
house
right at the very end of the day uh to
see like their parrots and macaws
and they had a kestrel which is a tiny
falcon
it's literally about this big and i put
it up on uh
no she handed it to me on my hand and so
i'm holding him and really like it kind
of hurts
to have them sitting on your hand
because their their talons are like
but it the force isn't much and they
don't weigh much so it didn't really
hurt but it's it it's one of those
things that your brain thinks it should
hurt more than it actually does because
you've got these needles that are poking
you like a cat kind of
yeah yeah yeah so i'm like whoa and this
is crazy and then it jumps up and lands
on my head and then immediately goes
down to my shoulders
and so i have this kestrel just sitting
on my shoulder which is super sweet
but also probably the most intimidating
thing i faced that entire day
for one reason i would look so this
guitar
i would look over and the kestrel is
just sitting there inches away from my
eyeball yeah just ready to pick honestly
like i was putting a tremendous amount
of trust into this bird here because
it's like
i was afraid like i took a selfie video
of it
i looked over at it and he does one of
these things like
and i was like okay don't bite me
[Laughter]
all you have to do is just like do a
little peck and i don't have an eyeball
anymore
yeah it just licks your dick move man
but that's
that's actually that's my i do kestrel
the smallest falcon
it's a tiny falcon very very small
very ugly is the only just as deadly
legit like bird story i have i mean i
know
you've probably heard it a couple times
at this point um i think i probably told
you guys
uh did i say the story on the podcast
last time where i was feeding some
french fries oh yeah
dude no this is sad yeah so i learned
more about it it was a castle basically
i was a
pigeon no it wasn't even a pigeon it was
like a finch i had just
come out of a joshua tree and i was i'd
gone through jack-in-the-box so i was
eating i was in my uh
old convertible at the time and i was
just throwing like tiny little french
fries
out into the street or in the parking
lot and like all these birds were around
eating them i was like
eat bird eat i don't know if that's good
for the bird or not i feel bad if it is
but uh at one point like i went to eat
and i look back and like all the birds
are gone i was like that's weird
where'd they go so i throw another
french fry out there and this little
bird comes hopping out like the most
adorable bird comes hopping out of this
this uh bush in front of my car and then
one moment it was the little bird
and the next moment it was a bigger bird
because literally the kestrel
had flopped like dove and literally dive
bombed
the bird like just wings
i just lured this bird to its death
without realizing it and she's
and so like i was telling the story to
anita the person who runs the falconry
experience and she's like oh yeah i was
kestrel she was probably sitting up on a
on a tv tv a telephone pole like right
above you just waiting for that exact
thing to happen so you
you made that happen i was like that
does not make me feel anything
it reminds me of like galaxy quest man
when they like
go to that little mining planet the
little like alien guy comes out he's
like
oh and there she's like oh he's so cute
and then like oh he's devoured by the
rest of them
like all of his friends yeah
nature's pretty crazy nature's
it's totally beyond all
yeah it's beyond everything it's it's
just it just is
yeah but the thing is like we need
predators like that you know it's not
like
oh they're hurting the cute bird you
know they're like they're
this is all part of a balanced ecosystem
you know yeah it's way beyond us
you were trying to do a good deed by
feeding a bird and you fed too
i mean like speaking of like the you
know the the
circle of life there it's like um i i
read up a little bit a while ago on how
uh
removing the wolves from yellowstone
literally
changed the the rivers within
yellowstone
and and so i mentioned that and then
anita just took it away from there and
she just started
she knew the story perfectly i was like
wow okay and it's the idea that like you
remove the wolves suddenly all the
the prey uh don't have a predator to
keep them in control so they graze more
and it literally changes how like the
rivers start expanding or something like
that mm-hmm are you you might be able to
tell the story better oh no
no no no no um
i i was yeah because it's like now the
the the prey that normally would have
predators to keep them lower
they eat all the grass around the rivers
and the rivers start expanding
it can trickle down like because like
there'll be overpopulation sometimes
because like
they won't get cold basically you know
by the predator right insects
overpopulating
um gotcha okay like yeah it's it can get
really crazy
it's just kind of it was very
interesting to find how delicate the
balance is
for something like that and so that's
why uh the bird laws are in place
to like to keep the you have to have a
gps unit on these birds
so that uh you don't have like for these
foreign birds i should say the
immigrants you got to keep track of the
wow jesus so my question is who enforces
these bird laws is there like a special
bird law agency like
i'm not sure because anita was saying
that like if
if we if we actually put our camera on a
peregrine falcon and someone like
complained they could lose their license
and then all of the birds would get
taken away like it's a big deal so i
assume there's some sort of regulatory
agency involved
dude they're just birds and suits holy
[ __ ] like penguins
this is the baby
oh god so the reason why they have to
keep the gps trackers on these uh
foreign birds is because if they
accidentally get unleashed into the wild
they could
start cross breeding with the local
wildlife and completely change the local
the delicate local ecosystem that i was
just describing
you know apparently it's a big deal so
which is why i was a little bit confused
about the whole like domestic bird laws
you know
because like it's forcing people to
bring in aliens and
like i mean alien species into another
place yeah and like what if they get
away in the production
like what if they get away from the
trainer then you have like what you've
just described happening i mean yeah
you'd get
fined i imagine on top of losing i mean
there's a lot of
i think the goal there is to not take
not to exploit
yes definitely natural species i think
is the goal
if it you know who knows if it actually
works
that way in the application of the law
you know you can say with relative
certainty like the motivation for it
is like hey we're gonna protect you know
protect the native species but yeah i
mean i'm glad you're doing the video i'm
glad that
you're you're doing it this way because
honestly like
you know it gets said a lot but like the
the more people know about
just the natural world like the better
off
we will all be because you are
absolutely right it is super delicate
and like
you know there's there's too much going
on right now with respect to like
you know the the fishing of the oceans
and just the general pollution that
humanity is causing on the globe now
you know most of it's coming america
does a pretty good job of like
putting in place like economic and
environmental restrictions that sort of
you know help
but like it's it's you know the pro the
problem is it's like it's
it's debatable it's so f yeah i mean
it's debatable you're absolutely right
but like
it's beyond just us you know it's beyond
just like
and so but my point is like the more
that we can
get content out there that displays a
little bit of that even if it's just a
little bit yeah
a little bit of awareness goes a long
way yeah yeah um you know it's like uh
you know leo dicaprio had that uh
documentary that he put out a few years
back called before the flood
yep yeah and it's all about climate
change it's all about like
all these different ways to you know try
to be better about you know
not contributing to the environment and
he got so much hate he got so much
uh um you know controversy surrounding
that because he had to fly all over the
world to shoot all these scenes for the
movie
and they're like you like how like what
is your carbon footprint
for like just to make this movie you
hypocrite and it's like but at the same
time he made this movie that was seen by
millions of people
that made them aware were as they
probably wouldn't have been
so does that offset his contributions
and the argument is that it does
yeah it's hard to say it does um yeah
but yeah i mean i guess yeah what i was
going to say a moment ago is that
what uh i've noticed there there are a
lot of birds of prey in
cities like i keep noticing them around
here not here specifically but like i'll
be on the highway
like you talk that's cool and and so i
mentioned that she's like oh yeah
it's because you know when we're putting
in all of these new buildings and
pushing the wildlife out of the city
it pushes all the bigger wildlife out
but the smaller wildlife remains aka
rodents and that is prime food for birds
of prey and that is why they
have also remained in the city imagine
for a hawk how easy it is it's well lit
you don't have any grass anywhere you
just have rodents like
running around in between dumpsters and
stuff dude we had such a bad mice
problem
in in my uh last apartment so apparently
uh we had orkin come over to our house a
couple months back to kill all the black
widows at our house oh fun
and oh yeah i know it was awful routine
routine inspection day
anyway uh he was like uh he was talking
about how
uh in in my area of the city the rodent
uh like mice and rats there the
population has exploded over the last
like four or five months
like we're talking four or five hundred
percent and so ev like
the number of calls they've gotten to
deal with rodents have
have exploded like way more than the
rodents have exploded
i was trying to make like a literal joke
but it didn't really come out that way
yeah
like the rodents aren't exploding
they're literally not exploding yeah
there's a problem
we need more exploding rodents i wonder
if there's any cool footage of like
birds of prey in a city like well any
big city
but like new york or you know
did a whole like urban canyon urban
episode i'm not sure if they did birds
of prey but it's really interesting
it's kind of the same vein as what
you're talking about it's like all these
animals that have adapted to urban
living around the world
and it's a really cool episode
definitely i have planners too on
blu-ray i'm gonna have to check that one
out yeah yeah it's it's
the photography is really cool yeah
there's like monkeys in india right yeah
central park yeah do you guys remember
uh remember
animal planet the tv channel yeah of
course uh who was the guy who was like
basically the american steve irwin
oh my gosh he was like the big like
animal like
yeah yeah uh but he was like american
like did stuff i remember watching his
show
his name jeff i feel like jeff jeff
mccormick yeah yeah yeah yeah
jeff goldblum
one of my earliest memories of uh
peregrine falcons was an episode he did
where he was in new york city in a cabin
and it was just all this building like
oh look up there oh and they're like
going around corners and it's like
b-roll of like
skyscrapers and stuff apparently there's
a big peregrine falcon
population in downtown manhattan
because they they just they roost on top
of these skyscrapers yeah and they fly
around they like do they get the
well with all the rats there oh yeah new
york
rats oh my gosh it's crazy we build all
these mega cities and like animals have
to adapt to them but they find a way you
know
nature's somehow finds a way find a way
i wonder if
uh if any of them ate the the famous nyc
subway pizza rat yeah what was the p
what's a pizza rat what remember
the gift that or the video that went
viral a couple years ago it was
literally this rat who just didn't give
an f about any people around
this piece of pizza it was a huge new
york style piece of pizza slice of pizza
dragging it up steps and it was like
taking a lot of effort just like
carrying it up step by step and some
person just recorded a video of it and
it was the most new york thing i've ever
seen
in my entire life yeah right the fact
that the rat had
no regard it's like i'm mocking you yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was like literally
there's like another person on this can
they gotta get a slice
come on i'm so funny about it that's
what's so funny about it because he's
like so new york
this piece of pizza is three times his
size
and he's trying to haul this thing
through the subway it was
nature finds a way jake yeah major fans
really
clearly it's gonna find a way to wipe us
out i'll tell you that
well it sounds like birds have it pretty
good in uh in the united states at least
if
you're a raptor you gotta find that they
get more breaks than a union worker
honestly like like you guys i'm glad you
guys got a flight out of them
yeah it's like oh no the birds need
their their manicure
oh yeah after 20 minutes they need to
give them the comments
what's it called what's it the catch the
crop the crop
it needs a crop manicure yeah
this reminded me of a tweet uh i thought
it was about birds but
i totally forgot it's actually about
fish so he said his his name is tim
urban
uh from the twitter account wait but why
fascinating guy he says
feed a man to fish feed him for a night
teach a man to fish feed him for a
lifetime
teach a man to make a.i the ai does all
the fishing and everyone is fed forever
then the ai accidentally kills all the
people and the fish win
[Laughter]
circle of life that is
i'm glad you guys got some rad footage
and i can't wait to see the video
also chase came out with us and and ran
a second camera
between his first shoot that was his
first uh shoot actually uh
operating a camera normally he's editing
visual effects
react or helping with the crew cuts or
back in the day with node
yeah and he did well yeah he did and he
was excited to be out on an actual
location shoot with us it was a fun time
yeah he did well good
awesome yeah he's uh he's been asking if
he could go on
uh a trip or two a filming trip or two
so i was glad we were able to
accommodate that yeah it was good yeah
i i can i can see him doing it although
he he did uh say that he didn't have the
confidence to use the zoom lens
so you ended up using those lens yeah i
sniped those birds
i shot those birds good son um
okay so the last few weeks have been
pretty crunchy because not only because
you guys obviously were out filming but
also because
you know we were trying to find a place
for
the nft drop that we just did today
crypto art drop yes yeah sorry i mean
it's not it's it's
you're not wrong i just i'm starting to
realize that people are
are uh there is a difference between an
nft and crypt art because crypto art is
a subset of
or rather an application of an nft sure
yeah
an mft is just the piece of the
blockchain you can put anything on there
right
yeah yeah i mean including art you can
you only have a certain amount of
information you can store in there so
you can't really
like the you can't store an image there
and i remember my
link to a database yeah so that's how
it's currently working is it actually
points to a database and there's a lot
of
there's some potential issues
surrounding that like if
uh any of these crypto art platforms go
down or go out of business and their
servers get shut down
then uh your token kind of becomes
worthless
um right because it's specifically like
it's baked into the token where it's
pointing
interesting but on top of that there's
still information that is tied like
uh description title words and you get
all that is actually stored in the token
itself
and that is where uh i i see a lot of
value in an nft a non-fungible token
because you can't duplicate it
you can't destroy it you can't uh you
know forge it
and right now it's pointing to these
servers i think ipfs
is the type of server that these images
are currently being stored on
and they're supposedly kind of hack
proof uh tamper proof
uh won't go offline it wouldn't but
there's some there they
they could wouldn't it be the same case
if the
like federal reserve
computers or the federal treasury
computers like went down i mean i
is can't the same argument be made like
obviously it's happening at a much
smaller scale when you're talking about
like a
crypto art site or yeah i mean i i don't
know anything
about the federal reserve to have an
opinion on that well we're off the gold
standard
we have been for a long time so it's all
just kind of nervous now
even more robust you know for for all
those purposes but like
i mean technically if any computer
system went down you would lose
everything on that computer system
except for the blockchain
because of its distributed nature uh
it's like it's like a
uh because it is distributed there's no
like single like
uh place where it's stored it's just
kind of like kind of stored everywhere
all at once
so so why take that this like the super
new amazing like open source uh
vehicle for all these things right or
sorry i don't know if it's
maybe not open source but but what's the
word i'm looking for it's it's
transparent fully transparent right
yeah you can always see the interactions
it's had it's trackable
yeah yeah why take that and then say oh
i'm gonna run a crypto art website
and be the only place to hold the
information that verifies the ownership
of this like
that seems very backwards to me like why
are these websites not
able to distribute this information
elsewhere regarding who owns what piece
and
well it is what these tokens are tied to
like you just said
like the tokens are are separate from
the crypto art platforms like makersplay
super rare nifty gateway
uh open c wearable uh async art there's
all these different places
um the token can be exchanged and
whatnot but
where the file path for that image is
stored
is on a server somewhere and i this is
where i i don't quite
know enough about the specifics of that
to really talk about it but
i sometimes i think it's stored on like
say maker's place their own server
uh sometimes like i mentioned ipfs i
think is the
is the acronym for it and i don't know
enough about that
because there's it's supposedly a way to
kind of combat the issue that i just
mentioned um
but there are still some vulnerabilities
with it i think i don't know it's
yeah it's it's oh this technology is so
new
that yeah it's it's like we're still
figuring out like the biggest problem
with it right now is the fact that it's
running on
ethereum 1.0 currently and that's
incredibly energy
wasteful um because
i mean i guess we can get into it a
little bit here it runs off
this protocol called proof of work and
basically what that means is that
in order to uh authorize a transaction a
whole bunch of computers
have to run this really complicated uh
puzzle
essentially like you know how when you
when you hear about like cracking a
password that's like
200 characters long or something like
that the brute force method method
would take like hundreds of years or
something like that because where you
have to try every permutation
that's kind of how it's working here so
in order to actually
find the correct password you have to
have just a tremendous number of
computers all kind of working on it at
the same time and then eventually one of
them gets lucky
which is why the blockchain is so cool
because you're you're harnessing the
power of all these processors
or press processors and putting them to
one task yeah yeah
but unfortunately yeah and that's one
way to uh and
and we can get into the nitty-gritty of
how that works and i
yeah again i don't know specifically
enough to talk about that here but
basically what it comes down to is that
once one computer
finds the correct code uh to solve the
you know the puzzle
all the other computers that were
working on it now move on to the next
one it means that all of the energy they
just spent trying to get to there is now
wasted
and so something like 90 percent of the
energy uh ends up
kind of being like just oh it's just
wasted energy like imagine like
going down the street to pick up your
mail and it's like oh someone else
already got the mail okay cool i'm gonna
go down the street to the next mailbox
oh someone else already grabbed that
mail okay
cool i'll go to the next oh i got the
mail it's like a foot race like all the
other runners who didn't win are still
freaking exhausted
like they're just a little bit like that
and so that's where all of the
uh the controversy is surrounding the
environmental impact of
of uh crypto in general is coming out
right now unfortunately
a lot of that controversy is being for
for
an incorrect reason specifically
targeted at nfts because they're
they're more complex to solve and and
uh so someone there's a couple people
who kind of like turn this into a big
deal
uh that other people writing articles
made into a much bigger deal like they
didn't intend for this to be
as big of a deal as it is but basically
they they made some calculations
uh estimating how much carbon dioxide is
being emitted
uh based off of how much energy it was
was used to
basically calculate that transaction and
uh
more recently we've kind of started
figuring out that those numbers were
incorrect
and and so a lot of the basis for the
environmental concerns surrounding nfts
are not rooted and completely in fact
there are still concerns there there are
like many many asterisks involved just
to put it
just to put that into context i mean
that information that you're just
talking about
was coming out as recently as like three
weeks ago
oh it's coming out every day so what's
crazy is that like yeah there'll be an
argument with
like some sources and whatnot and and
and then there'll be a counter argument
to that with some other sources
and what i'm seeing a lot of the time
especially on twitter is that these
things are being shared with straight-up
incorrect information
but because like you're seeing incorrect
information you've shared on twitter
no it's being shared everywhere
twitter's just kind of like the main hub
for
uh the cryptocurrency information got it
but like there's this one
talking about how crypto art is a
pyramid scheme and it was
made in like this nice little um like
infographic with squiggly lines it was
kind of cute art style
that cursed or what what's that channel
yeah it was kind of like that art style
and it was you know and talking about
how
crypto art is a pyramid scheme and
here's why except it's like
literally half the things they said are
just not true
like it's false and so but people are
sharing it as if it's true it's it's
blowing my mind because it's like we saw
a lot of this surrounding like the
political landscape last year you know
just with misinformation and people just
running with it
it was a big problem and we're seeing
that exact same thing happening in in
the nft science i understand it people
it's it's you know
killing the environment is an emotional
thing it's like it cuts
you know especially when people are like
why
is all of this damage occurring quote
unquote damage
to only benefit a small number of people
and that's where a lot of the
the because it feels like you're
like a small number of people are
putting a lot of harm on to a large
number of people
compared to like say you know the meat
industry you know beef
eating beef is really bad for the
environment because of their farts
and the sheer amount of water it takes
to grow the food to feed the animals
but at the same time this is an industry
that feeds
millions of people billions and millions
of people work in this industry
so this is not something that you can
just easily like kind of move away from
and and that you know as bad as it is
it's kind of like
it's it's rooted really hard whereas
nfts
even if it's less of a problem it
i'm just talking about the arguments
people are using i'm not saying
that this is actually the case and so
even though it's less of a problem
because it's only benefiting a small
number of people it is therefore worse
but i mean look like it's it's it's
the the emotion behind it makes sense
yes like like look if if you if i just
told you and you accept it as fact that
there was a small number of people
harming a large number of people that
would be a cause for concern
for anyone right get that guillotine man
let's go so so and rusty
obviously like this comes with
a context which no one quite knows
fully so complex dude like
how can you know exactly how much carbon
your one transaction on the blockchain
is making so that's that's the issue
is that there are many different ways to
calculate this and none of them are
totally correct and in fact even in the
original there's a website called
cryptoart.wtf that that this is like the
start of it uh
mimo aitken i think was the author of it
and uh he just wanted to bring up
something that no one was really talking
about at the time
he didn't want it to be a big thing he
was just like oh yeah by the way you
know like this is kind of like
something to think about but then of
course you know you get the big
websites the big uh news sites they
they latch on to that and they just they
take this stuff as
is and then write big articles with
really really catchy headlines
and so then that gets distributed to the
whole mass of people who just kind of
read the headline maybe skim through the
article
and just uh take it as true this is
something that i've been researching
pretty heavily
for the last several weeks and i still
feel like i have a ways to go before i
understand this better they're like i've
been doing
so much reading hours and hours of
reading and
and i still feel like i don't have a
complete grasp of
of everything because the more i
research the more i realize i don't
understand
so if i'm struggling to understand this
i guarantee you
the people who just read a single
article or five articles on
uh on medium or whatever aren't gonna
yeah
aren't gonna know and so yeah i've been
i've been talking with a few experts
uh in both the the cryptocurrencies
field uh
uh ecological impact field and and
and and crypto art specifically and i'm
trying to compile uh resources i'm gonna
actually try to interview these people
on camera
so that eventually we can make a video
just kind of distilling this one
one of my main worries though is that
like i'm trying really hard to be as
unbiased as possible
but at the same time here we are
producing crypto art
by its very nature by definition i am
biased because part of me is going to
want to justify
why i'm doing this sure but at the same
time i'm i do want to get
to a correct answer at the bottom of
this yeah you should seek the correct
answer more
more over anything else because honestly
if the correct answer
is actually it's terrible then it's
probably not something
you're going to want to strongly engage
in you know yeah so right now it seems
like regular
uh nfts just meanting a single edition
something
isn't that bad like the entire
blockchain consumes less than 0.1
percent
of all the energy reproduce compared to
like 70 percent
going towards transportation like all of
our gas cars like
can i say the the like dollar figure
that we came to because
not yet not yet okay because i i still
don't have a high degree of confidence
that that number is correct
uh all i'll say then is that if we do
continue after this charity auction
doing nft stuff on the channel
we'll be doing carbon offsets directly
times like 100 of the worst math
projection possible
that we know of we'll take that and like
times it by a hundred and just
donate that to carbon offset well until
we know
just finished this whole charity auction
on nifty gateway over the weekend
that was specifically for carbon
offsetting they raised like six and a
half million dollars holy moly
uh and in a stroke of an instant they
completely offset the entirety of the uh
nft industry however another huge
asterisk because they're the asterisks
are endless
uh it's it's what's called greenwashing
which is the idea that like
it's kind of wishful thinking there's no
way to actually remove the carbon
dioxide out of the air
and so one of the ways that when we say
carbon offset it's like oh we're going
to plant some trees
and it's like well a tree over the
course of 20 years only removes this
much carbon dioxide and it's not really
a
useful amount and so it's
it's not actively offsetting
anything and it's going to this
organization that was just made so who
knows what they're going to do
so there's a lot of kind of confusing
points surrounding this
i feel like that everyone involved is
patting their backs a little too hard
but it's still it's still good it's
still like are you not are you telling
me that the world as we know it is a lot
more complicated than it seems
and that just from reading headlines you
can't really derive the total truth
about something
so you shouldn't rush to immediate
judgment just because you read something
some or someone said something
yes see oh crazy
see let me let me ask you this run do
you know
what kind of office offsetting actually
works like
like what are they don't know what sort
of offsetting actively works
yet okay uh but that's not to say that
carbon offsetting
doesn't work it is still probably
definitely good to at least do
so what nick was saying that like for
every nft drop a portion of that is
going to go towards carbon offsetting
and uh the numbers we uh nico came up
with
uh basically it's a lot less than you
would think
we're talking like dozens or hundreds of
dollars rather than thousands or
millions
and so you i think what we're gonna end
up doing is being like all right however
much we gotta offset let's multiply that
number by a hundred just to put a
blanket-wide
thing covering everything but here's the
thing ethereum i just said waste a
tremendous amount of energy
so does youtube youtube consumes about
the same energy as
the entire ethereum network oh [ __ ] and
and unplug your ethernet cord
one of the guys i'm talking about i
mentioned this and i still
i okay turn your turn your display to
240p minimal display listen to this i'm
about to blow your mind
now i got i uh i don't know that this
number is for a fact i still gotta
actually confirm these numbers with him
but he mentioned this
and he said a one minute video with 500
000 views has the same environmental
impact as a single nft
wow well now i feel like a dick
what i was thinking the reason why this
is a whole big problem is the fact that
it is
so transparent that is the real thing
causing all of these uh this outrage
because
you can point to that number and be like
you see you did this
i'm pointing at this number of how much
energy was used and therefore how much
carbon you put in the air
this is something i'm pointing at that
you did
whereas you know like i can't point at
amazon and be like well that
amazon one day delivery i got there's no
number i can point to to say that's
the carbon footprint for it you can
calculate it you can like
do a tremendous amount of homework to
actually figure out the whole pipeline
uh and all the emissions that come from
that but the fact that it's not
transparent
no one's aware of it no one's outraged
over it but nfts
are an easy thing to point at especially
when you have a guy making 70 million
dollars i mean a lot of the comments
i've been in the arguments i've been
reading on multiple platforms and not
only associated with our
crypto related stuff but like just in
general in general yeah
like has been i think it's a mix of like
almost like the environmental thing and
the concern is one thing but there's
also i think a lot of people just like
i don't get this and i'm actually
because this seems pointless
it seems pointless and then exactly the
environmental impact thing on top of
that compounds that because it's like
well
it's harmful and it's pointless and then
they read stories about how uh people
are getting their art stolen and
profiting off of that so it's like this
is hurting
the little guys which stealing people's
work and profiting off of that
is a problem that actually is like
legitimately a bit of a problem however
this is a byproduct of the fact that
this is such early days
this is the same reason why like you
know media companies were pissed at
youtube
back in the early days of youtube
because people were literally ripping tv
shows and movies and uploading them to
youtube
they're feeling the same way the little
artists are feeling now yeah exactly
exactly and you used to be able to watch
movies on youtube
it was one of ten yeah yeah
you know like they had a billion dollar
lawsuit against them
yeah viacom yeah and that's google when
google bought them the whole
conversation
around them buying youtube was google's
gonna all of a sudden be responsible for
this billion dollar
uh liability and uh you know they worked
their way through it but
um and that's now no longer that much of
a problem we still face bootlegging
every now and then people ripping our
videos posting them to tech talk i
literally just saw a tick tock the other
day
had millions of views of of all of the
vfx shots from the star wars video i
made
of like you know millennium falcon on
the highway no credit whatsoever no
credit at all
uh i think eventually enough people
commented that he mentioned credit in
the comment but
it was like buried it doesn't bother me
i'm not i don't i'm not bothered by that
sort of thing that much anymore
i've been seeing my freaking youtube
videos on ads that i'm not getting
compensated for
at all like so often over the last
couple years i've become a little numb
to it
um i mean that's not to say that we're
not you know
trying thankfully now the audience is
like amazing
and this is so incredible all the
comments are always the policing that
they've
done on this just like the self-policing
just from viewers is
impeccable thanks everyone i'm i'm not
saying that ironically like i mean that
that isn't yeah you're absolutely right
we get emails
almost every day of somebody sending us
a video that we didn't know was out
there that's
just to complete rip and rip and re
you know uh so yeah but yeah so to get
back to what you're saying
i think probably a bigger problem than
the transparency fact
is what you said people don't see the
point and it's because it's kind of
confusing
it's straight up hard to explain no one
sees the value no one
and because they don't see the value
they don't see the point uh and
the you can't really explain well like
artists are making more money now
yeah that's great for artists right and
they're like yeah who cares
no one cares about yours there's a
reason why they're called starving
artists no one cares about artists
if i told you that a man opened a bottle
of water
and drank it and he made 70 million
dollars
you'd kind of be pissed off yeah
no i want to figure out what what bottle
you have of course
but you like your initial like you know
you're walking by you don't have time
for this information like i
i don't care i'm on my way to work i'm
on i got stuff to do
you hear this thing out of the corner of
your ear you just got an 80
parking ticket that like put you in the
negative you're like [ __ ] man
and you hear and that's all you hear and
then the new york times writes
man sells a jpeg for 69 million dollars
and of course but they're going to be
pissed yeah but what people aren't
taking into context
is the 13 years of work
that have gone into people's collection
which make it
valuable in this particular place at
this particular time
which has never existed before and who
knows how
you know who knows what's going to
happen yeah you know also you know
people say like what was wrong with the
current system there's already current
ways for artists to thrive right now and
it's like well
is there like oh yeah commissions and
it's like oh really
yeah have you tried
or trying to get someone to buy your
commission it's like it's
it's people from the outside being like
oh this system's already in place it's
it's good enough and it's like no
it's not like uh otherwise you can't
blame the artist for like seeing
a system that is already functioning and
saying oh
i can make money doing this and like
actually make what i think i'm worth
well
and more and let's go you can't partner
with artists can
monetize the work is like one way is
like you know selling t-shirts and i can
get into that you know the amount of
energies used to just
make t-shirts but also to go to
conventions to do all that there's all
kinds of
uh fees in place and like when you
actually start comparing the
environmental impact of like
uh art shows trade shows selling a whole
bunch of t-shirts it actually
is it's actually slightly better
for the uh environment to sell an nft
unknown to like go to comic con to sell
your t-shirts a note on those
conventions
i used my dad was a union carpenter when
i was growing up and sometimes
he would hire me onto these like
convention gigs where they just needed
extra hands to come in and like and like
set up the conventions
i didn't know that yeah we would so what
would happen is we would go into these
conventions
and it would be like a changeover right
and so like one is ending and the next
one is starting
and they would take all the carpet from
the prior convention because it wasn't
the right
color or texture or whatever it was
and just roll it up and get rid of it
wow yeah like i i don't know if it went
straight to the dumpster
or somebody else was like trying to buy
it the carpet scabs just
grabbed it and like you're talking about
chuck e cheese you're talking about like
you know imagine it was the minneapolis
it was the mini twin cities convention
center which is like this oh wow 100 100
000 square foot building and and imagine
one of those whole halls you just
hey just get rid of that carpet it's not
part of the next convention because it's
it and and you know how the games are
like built and
and bought and purchased for these
one-week trade shows
so much man that what do you do with him
after that what happens to all that
stuff
you gotta think who knows i tell you
what man this outrage has actually been
getting to me like
uh i had to completely disengage from
from reading the comments on the videos
lately like yeah uh if you guys leave a
comment on this video i will not read it
ren oh my god you have to watch this
i'll read it for you i have to watch
this joel haver commercial or this joel
haver uh
episode that he put on his youtube
called called uh
my friend quit social media for two days
or something
oh i saw that it's so funny yeah yeah
yeah i will spoil it for you
but yeah so like what it comes down to
is that like you know i i've done so
much research into this and
every time i try to engage with someone
to try to change their mind
i have like a small chance of convincing
them
because my arguments are usually not
very good i'm not a good debater i don't
i
and i'm still working on getting all my
facts straight and whatnot
and so it's it's so hard just to engage
one person
and let's say i do succeed and i
convince one person well guess what
there's a million people behind them in
line it's like facing off against a
zombie horde
and so i've realized this is just i
don't have the energy for it
like oh man dude sunday was really bad i
was in a really bad
state on sunday because i have this
small section in that video talking
about like listen
don't be mad at the artist over this
they're not at fault here
and i some people are saying like i just
came across as like condescending
or patronizing and like completely
uh and i what i didn't take into account
is that like uh
i was just making the assumption right
off the bat that people would have to
take what i said
as fact like listen this is uh there are
problems but like
what you actually hear isn't the thing
and then of course you know they ignored
me on that
uh and and then all they hear is like oh
our artists are at fault like we're
our artists are not at fault like don't
don't get angry at the artists
and i'm like because that was the one
message i wanted them to come away with
is that like you know
yeah don't get angry at as artists and
sure enough they got angry
and and i i read through the comments a
little bit on sunday and i immediately
was like this i can't handle this
cannot handle don't let that stuff like
ruin your day it's it it's totally worth
it man
it's i know and it happens to all of us
from time to time yeah definitely we're
human beings just as much as the next
person
yeah but the difference here is that
because there's an actual like
the outrage is different than because
i've experienced plenty of criticisms
over the years being online for the last
decade you know but usually it's on the
line of like
i don't like the work you just put out i
miss the old work you put out like i
don't like the direction you're going
now or like i disagree with what you
said or what you did it's never personal
you know
sometimes it's kind of personal like i
don't like you
but like this time it's like wow how
dare you ruin the world
for the rest of us you killed all the
seals and it's like obviously
really obvious really maybe i'm not
being hyperbolic
it was it was something like how dare
you
you guys might as well club a bag of
baby seals
something literally like that and it's
like bro the blockchain's been around
for free
how long you know and again it's like
i'm not excusing the blockchain
and it does use a tremendous amount of
energy but it is in transition right now
it is actually going to a whole
different system of how it operates
called proof of stake i talked about
proof of work earlier
i don't know enough about how proof of
stake works to really talk about it
right now but basically
it consumes 99.9 less energy
than than the current 1.0 so it's like
you got proof of stay you have layer two
technologies
these are all basically more efficient
versions of the blockchain and they're
currently being rolled out there's
several
uh networks out there already so one of
the things i'm gonna be looking into is
the
tezos tevos something like that
network is it's a one it's a
proof-of-stake network for nfts that is
already being used oh cool but the
problem is that the marketplace isn't
strong behind it so there's not really
much value there currently
ethereum is going to go to ethereum 2.0
which is proof of stake at some point
the roadmap for that is like
end of this year maybe early next year
uh i wonder if this whole thing has like
injected that with some more like fuel
though like putting some fuel in that
fire you know and it'll go faster now
yeah no exactly it's it's it's people
are like i feel like
this whole thing going back to the kind
of the
the anger verse you know the actual like
trigger verse
verse like true like environmental
concern right
versus like the anger of i don't
understand this and why it wouldn't
possibly be doubtful
it's it's the arguments that can be made
are are don't really hold much water
because it kind of dips into what about
ism
it's like oh well wow are you vegan what
does your amazon
history look like what was like how many
t-shirts do you
like all those things aren't a good way
to like argue for
in favor of nft holier than thou like
yeah yeah and it's like but at the same
time it's like that is
an issue because they are getting
outraged at this tiny little
subset of all these other problems that
they're ignoring you know it's like
getting real it's like they don't know
all that exists because people are just
this has forced people to now have to
learn about
the blockchain because it's not easy to
learn no it isn't and a lot of people
have just said okay bitcoin
i remember when it got really big and
then it all crashed i knew that was
going to happen right because it's
bitcoin
and then they don't care about it and
then now they see this you know on all
the papers you've got these headlines
i was i've i've talked like geez i've
had conversations with my parents
friends of mine from back home all
wondering like what is this
like how does this work and it's like uh
well we're all figuring out but
yeah and now you have to too cause like
you want to know what's going on
but like it's rough there's a lot of
things there's a few factors that are
making for a really crazy cocktail it's
hard to understand it's uh easy to seem
pointless and your chances are the only
things you do understand about it are a
few headlines
that pretty much all say it's ruining
the environment
or stealing someone's work which it
partly is
yeah but like but it's getting better
tiny bit
compared to to what people actually
think it's doing
like i'm actually talking with i'm not
even talking about comparing it to say
amazon or the top 100 corporations that
are actually responsible for 70
70 of the emissions in the world that is
a fact
um yikes um like i'm talking about like
even within
the arguments that are like this amount
of this nft released this much carbon
dioxide it's like they're actually
looking at one open edition which was
like
2 000 nfts minted all at once and so it
we're talking like numbers that are
actually straight up incorrect
that their arguments are based on yeah
because an open edition of 2000 nfcs
does not represent
the average mintage right and that is
actually why we didn't do an
open edition of that would be so high
just it would be
crazy that like it would i don't know
why you would ever do that but
well if you're people and you know
you're gonna you know like nifty gateway
they do open editions but they're those
pieces are selling for like you know 500
to a thousand dollars i literally
watched this person
make 1.4 million dollars in seven
minutes
because it was an open edition for 999
dollars i forget his name
uh that anger you feel it i feel it too
a little bit
and 1400 of them sold in seven minutes
okay let's do the math this is amazing
can we do the math really quick
can we do the math really quick okay
they got 1.4
in gross and then their gas fees to mint
all of that
took it down to one and then they got
that much
to one probably it's really expensive
one million yeah
probably 400 k on gas no the gases the
gas fees change
it depends on the time of day you meant
it depends how much effort
how long ago was that like recently no
it was like a month and a half ago
it was like probably less than but if
you did that now that's what it would be
and so but guess fees traditionally has
been somewhere between like
five and ten dollars recently they've
been upwards of like forty to ninety
dollars and depending on the time of day
it can be upwards of two hundred but
that's
rare and you can so the whole thing
about it's not that rare anymore
okay sure yeah no i mean it still is a
little bit but the thing about ethereum
is that it's uh
the gas fees are all completely based
off of demand at the moment and what
you're paying for is a slot in line
and so you can there's three different
options for gas fees you can be like the
slow route
the medium fast route or the like vip
route and uh they go up in price
and all the gas fee is is just paying
the miners who are actually doing the
calculations
and so like when you hear like oh i'm
i'm i've got my mining station
they're literally just making money off
of gas fees essentially for all the
transactions
and it's unfortunate that it's called
gas because it's like yeah right it's
like it
further cements the the confusion
you might as well call it seal bags
it's not a good term i guess what it
comes down to is there
are valid reasons to be concerned about
nfts
majorly because it's it's a very new
technology
no one fully understands how this works
yet it's an emerging
industry um yeah
it's i lost my thought i totally lost it
i mean that's i think the trains arrived
man
the trains at the station it's complex
and we're learning
we're we're trying to absorb all this
info yeah and uh so it's like no matter
what i say
there's always gonna be someone who uh
is gonna come
come in with their argument and their
concern and be like oh well
they're valid i've had more people tell
me that they're disappointed in me
and angered at me yeah in the last
couple weeks
than i have ever on the internet that
one is it's not a fun comment reading
that no it's
disappointing it's like i'm not angry
i'm just i'm so disappointed in you i
can't believe you would do this i have
to like
like anytime someone says like oh i'm
unsubscribing i literally laugh because
i find that funny like i don't care if
you unsubscribe like whatever
but to say that you're disappointed in
me is like dang that actually kind of
stings
randy yeah let me tell you something
right now buddy
you make me proud i love you thanks jake
you're i love you jake you're one of my
best friends actually did you know that
i did not know that yeah well i mean you
know i've got friends
but i feel like everyone dude the whole
corridor crew here are some of my best
friends they're like i mean
like i hung out with people last year
during the pandemic it was
you guys it was just you guys
like i i don't have friends outside of
work that i hang out with
actively i have lots of friends outside
of work i have lots of friends period
well it's cause like working here is
like social well so it's like
for me i'm i'm kind of like an introvert
who's learned to be
you know able to be extroverted at times
but
working here it's very social yeah you
know especially when you're in the
studio with everyone
so when i get home i'm like my social
battery is done like no that's
really true absolutely i don't want to
go like meet up with someone else that's
like no dude i just gotta think about it
i think that's a pretty relatable thing
for most people yeah
social batteries are real even even
coming in here new it's like it was easy
to become friends with you guys
like because y'all are cool people and
we got a good group here shoot the show
i'm very proud of the crew that we have
and all of this all the times we've had
to trudge through the trenches
over the last 10 years yeah like that
that's you don't experience that with a
lot of people
in your life you know it's real
true yeah just keep that in mind next
time you read one of those comments
yeah and honestly i've i've already i've
already come to terms with any
disappointing comments i i'm saying this
so that anytime any anyone in the future
does say that like they're disappointed
me
i'm actually not gonna be bothered by it
like i'm already beyond it i'm
because i realized i i'm wasting my time
and energy by trying to respond to all
these people
what i where i need to focus my energy
and effort is into making a solid video
explaining that's going to be such a
good video for many reasons
um yeah just but it's getting this
information presented clearly
so intimidating to consider i bet man
because i i know even if i do the best
job i possibly can trying to address all
the different factors
and and however long it ends up being i
talked with a whole bunch of experts i
tried to be as unbiased as possible i
put it up
they're still going to be so many
comments
you already know that so don't worry
about that you know
i just want people to like me jake
i just want to be liked that's my number
one goal in life
i don't remember if it was it'll be fun
you have so many friends
i think it was it was i don't know if it
was mother teresa
or who said this but i just want mother
teresa to like
the ones who matter don't care
and the ones who care don't matter
something that was deep damn i had to
just like wow dwell on that
that just that just kind of like hit me
like a rocking sock
anyway um okay a lot going on thanks for
the time boys coming down and doing the
podcast
did we even like talk about the fact
that like our maker's place
our actual like 19 drop was today yeah
yeah
is going on right now yeah it's probably
made more money
yeah let's check christian can you check
how cool that is that we've raised
how much have we raised right now so
last i checked right before we came down
uh it was a hundred and seven thousand
dollars total between the six pieces
something happened to the goat the goat
offer
what's it at now uh because when i did
that calculation of 107
huh yeah went down to four
how does that work though because once
something's been in place for 15 minutes
i thought it's good
no no no the 15 minutes thing is at the
end of it all like someone places a bid
it increases the time by another 15
minutes or sorry it it extends the time
to 15 minutes
so that other people can get their extra
bids in somebody's here we go for a
while maybe they're disappointed in us
maybe they're disappointed in people
bullying peter either way
um it's been awesome so far and we've
been able to raise a bunch of money for
covet 19 relief so well in the first
five minutes
i totaled it up it was around 90 000 in
the first five minutes
now because of how bidding systems work
it's gonna
sit around and hover at that number for
most of the next 24 hours while the
auction is live
and then right at the last minute when
like time starts ticking down
then everyone's actually gonna start
putting in their offers and that's when
the bidding war happens so i wouldn't be
surprised if the number starts going up
quite a bit after that
or right at the end um whether so one
person it went
someone someone made a 4 000 offer and
then immediately someone else made like
a 44 000
offer on the goat picture with peter and
mike
and then someone else made it fifty
thousand four hundred and twenty dollars
sixty nine cents
and that was last i saw it so i guess
but maker's place is doing a little
differently
than i'm used to normally uh bids are
done
through the blockchain in ethereum and
it's like
publicly verifiable but i guess they're
doing in cash which means
the bids are happening on their server
which is good that means every single
time someone bids it's not actually a
transaction on the blockchain yeah it's
consuming less energy that's already
greater
or that's already better right off the
bat but i guess that means that there
might be complications where bids aren't
actually
real so maybe someone made a bid and
when they actually went to like charge
them for
like a whole put a hold on that like it
bounced i don't know
i don't know maybe it's again fake
business
that's a weird universe guys give us
give us a little bite so we can figure
this out and
and make some put some better
information out there for everyone to to
hopefully
grab it yeah yeah dude we are we are
actually donating
a ton of money to covet 19 relief yeah
and
we've never really done a charity thing
like on this level before
the only charity we've done before was
the one natalie ran last year for extra
life and that was 10k
and that was a big deal that was great
that was really cool dude that's
not to be taken for granted absolutely
not i think the fact that we
have an audience uh that can
support something of that scale
is just something to you know something
to take a tactical pause on and just
say hey pretty cool you know yeah
absolutely
yeah and it's like being able to uh ride
on the coattails of someone as famous
and renowned as people uh it didn't feel
right to just pocket that money
no oh yeah all right and i i don't think
he would have agreed i mean i in fact i
know he wouldn't have agreed to
to like work with us and like sell that
that if it's just conditions
yeah i mean yeah cause i mean dude
that's a it's a crazy amount of money to
basically just like yeah
but that's quite a coat tail right there
yeah yeah golden coat tail yeah
so but i remember mentioning to my
friend uh when we were talking about
this back in january my friend dawn
uh donalini and i mentioned it to him
that we were doing this
uh and and i was like oh yeah we're
gonna we're gonna donate it to charity
and he was instantly like red flag like
ooh
be careful man i was like what why he's
like you can't just say for charity no
one's gonna believe you and that'll
actually be
that'll end up backfiring you have to
have a specific charity in mind and this
is like before people even came by and
shot with us we were just like
we're just thinking out loud like oh
yeah all right we should definitely
donate this to charity
um and so when i mentioned it that that
and that's why we actually i
i forced nico i was like nico you have
to come up with a very specific charity
and this is again back in january early
days still
and he was like okay cool yeah not a
problem yeah but he he ended up having
to do the research to
find a specific charity to donate to
because that's something that we learned
having not really
having any experience doing charities
you can't just say it's for charity
you have to say it's for a charity
specifically
yeah and you need to be very you need to
do your due diligence
on the ones that you donate to because
like there's some shady charities that
will just pocket most of the money as
they
just they just managerial costs or
whatever they call it uh operating costs
yeah exactly so anyways
it's been a pleasure chatting with you
guys dude this is a long one yeah yeah
i need to go get a photo scan of the
street and uh
i guess i'm gonna play this out uh any
does anyone have any requests
because i probably don't know how to
play it free bird free bird
i don't know how to play wonder wall
but i'll sing you a song after all
hey that was good birds and beeple bits
[Music]
birds and people bits and
three two one